j'ai l'honneur monsieur le Président
d'engager la responsabilité du
gouvernement cela n'a pas été compris
par tous
je le regrette
un texte passé en force avec le 49-3
n'est pas toujours appliqué par la suite
la preuve en 2006 avec le CPE le contrat
première embauche un dispositif imaginé
pour lutter contre le chômage des jeunes
qui atteint alors 24%. il provoque une
forte opposition notamment en raison
d'une mesure une période d'essai de deux
ans avec possibilité de licencier sans
avoir à donner le motif
l'annonce provoque immédiatement la
colère de la Genèse mais le 9 février
2006 Dominique de Villepin passe le
texte en force à l'Assemblée nationale
en dégainant le 49,3
[Musique]
9.3 donc tout est fait pour que il n'y
ait pas véritablement d'explication
devant les Français à travers un débat
parlementaire c'est un véritable
après ce 49-3 explosif le mouvement
social s'intensifie des centaines de
milliers de manifestants se mobilisent à
Paris Marseille au Bordeaux mais aussi
dans des petites villes comme à Digne ou
Saint-Brieuc des petites villes comme
digne d'habitude calme et sans histoire
ont été le théâtre de cortège important
Poitiers Nord Châtellerault le pays
charentais en émoi
CPE pour cherche pigeon à exploiter
c'était le mot d'ordre à Toulouse de 40
à 80000 manifestants selon les chiffres
avec la présence inhabituelle de
nombreux salariés du prière
Dominique de Villepin persiste et le
texte est promulgué le 31 mars 2006 mais
revirement surprise le jour même Jacques
Chirac tient une allocution et annonce
la suspension de l'application du texte
j'ai entendu également des inquiétudes
qui s'expriment chez de nombreux jeunes
et chez leurs parents
et je veux y répondre
c'est pourquoi je demande au
gouvernement de préparer immédiatement
deux modifications de la loi sur les
points qui ont fait débat
la période de deux ans sera réduite à un
an
en cas de rupture du contrat le droit du
jeune salarié en connaître les raisons
sera inscrit dans la nouvelle loi
finalement face à la contestation le
gouvernement s'incline et Dominique de
Villepin en terre définitivement le CPE
le 10 avril 2006 le CPE est remplacé par
un dispositif en faveur des jeunes en
difficulté mais c'est le premier
ministre qui veut endosser la
responsabilité
déclaration depuis Matignon les mots
retraits et abrogations sont
soigneusement évitées j'ai proposé au
Président de la République qui l'a
accepté le remplacement de l'article 8
de la loi sur l'égalité des chances par
des mesures en faveur de l'insertion
professionnelle des jeunes les plus en
difficulté j'ai voulu agir vite
parce que la situation dramatique et le
désespoir de beaucoup de jeunes
l'exigent
cela n'a pas été compris par tous je le
regrette du CPE il ne reste rien si ce
n'est un exécutif affaibli et au plus
bas dans les sondages
[Musique]